over the past two decades ncis has
become one of the most popular
franchises in television history
making headlines every time a new
spin-off series is announced
such as the upcoming ncis hawaii and
every time an old spin-off series is
cancelled like ncis new orleans
but while drama is the name of the game
with ncis the biggest drama in the
show's history actually happened
off-screen and the biggest headlines
weren't about spin-offs but about
meltdowns the issue the sudden and
shocking departure of series star paulie
perette
perette of course was one of the show's
mainstays right from the pilot episode
in 2003
playing quirky fan favorite lab
technician abby sciutto
but in 2018 after 15 seasons perez
suddenly left the show to the surprise
of fans around the world
making her final appearance in the
season 15 finale episode two steps back
her departure was made even more
shocking when just after the episode
aired perette posted several tweets
alleging a toxic workplace
environment saying in part i've been
supporting anti-bullying programs
forever but now i know because
it was me if it's school or work that
you're required to go to
it's horrifying i left multiple physical
assaults
i really get it now stay safe nothing is
worth your safety
tell someone so what happened according
to the rap the behind the scenes drama
stemmed from an incident in 2016
where series star mark harmon reportedly
brought his dog to the ncis set
the dog then attacked a crew member
biting them in the face
luckily though the bite was near the eye
and there was no loss of vision
the crew member had to receive 15
stitches
what happened to you i was attacked by a
vicious dog
are you okay perette reportedly demanded
that the dog not be allowed on set
anymore and as a result
cbs executives reportedly asked harmon
to keep the dog in his trailer
this led to tension between the two
stars who reportedly agreed to no longer
film scenes together
which is why their characters rarely
appeared on screen together in season
15.
but that apparently didn't solve things
in 2019 after fans implored her to
return to the series she tweeted
no i am not coming back ever please stop
asking
i am terrified of harmon and him
attacking me i have nightmares about it
in a sense-deleted tweet perette posted
a photo of the injuries suffered by the
crew member from the dog bite and said
this happened to my crew member and i
fought like hell to keep it from
happening again
to protect my crew and then i was
physically assaulted for saying no
and i lost my job according to tmz the
physical assault occurred when harmon
allegedly body checked peret
which she believed to be an intentional
act of intimidation and retaliation for
the dog bite incident
but her beef apparently wasn't just
about the dog it was a culmination of
events and it wasn't just with harmon
but with the producers who she felt
empowered him in 2020 she tweeted there
are things
so racist and so misogynistic and so
homophobic and cruel that were set on
set at that show that i have never
spoken of because the language is so
hurtful
and y'all wondered why i quit those
producers are still there
all of them including him whatever the
specifics though perette has seemingly
moved on
though she has shut the door on an ncis
reunion she has mended fences with cbs
after they praised her for working to
ensure a safe workplace environment
she has also since declined to discuss
mark harmon and her departure from the
show
instead focusing on new endeavors and in
2020 she returned to cbs to star in the
comedy series broke
though it was canceled perez praised the
experience saying that the show quote
healed her oh my god oh my gucci
while it's sad to think that perette
will never return to ncis if leaving an
unhealthy work environment and finding a
more positive experience on another show
has helped paret heal
and restore her passion for acting then
that's what's important
fans may be disappointed by the
unlikelihood of abby's reunion but we're
all excited to see what perette does
next